[Musique]
j'ai toujours été le méchant
ça fait trois victimes avec la même arme
c'est quoi ça on les a trouvés aux
soldes votre actuelle il est nul je peux
faire autre chose pour vous quel est mon
numéro de chambre déjà c'est écrit
dessus
offre 10 millions de dollars à kout
corps au service
non
[Musique]
annuler le contrat je touche pas aux
enfants jamais public était très
attentivement le jeu fear estampillé où
vous aurez à faire moi
une jeune fille de 13 ans a été placée
tu étais ici tout nu oui qu'est-ce qui
se passe son nez sur
hugo crois que c'est un pro qui fait du
ménage fait d'illégal benson sera
vous êtes trop long pour les faire payer
il élimine les trafiquants intouchable
ils interfèrent avec une enquête
internationale vous avez dit qu'il ne
poserait aucun problème j'ai fait des
choses épouvantables
mais posez votre arme et on va discuter
je sais que vous êtes malade alors j'ai
pas le temps
si je meurs vous ne saurez jamais la
vérité mais c'est votre
bien croire que vous êtes un homme bien
un médecin
et si je n'y arrive pas ce sera vous
qu'ils devraient faire
les coupables doivent être punis donc il
quand vous voulez vous être juste
j'appelle bien justice
on va tous mourir ce qui compte c'est ce
qu'ont accompli avant
je
[Musique]